my neck hurts I've been having a lot of
diarrhea I had to take imodium a-d at
the airport again oh [ __ ] in Chicago oh
my god there was eight what happened I
was with Jade quatre proton and we got
there a little early and we went to this
like Italian breakfast place and there
these little sausages and I ate one and
I could hear my stove you know you know
the party started
oh yeah people are arriving you know I
mean there's like you know J yeah yeah
yeah and I gotta go so I go to the
bathroom it was one of those things like
I had to go right then and there and
then there was a line to the toilets
like eight dudes were leaning against a
wall no these guy white people take the
longest shits yeah they read right they
read taxes daily this is the music I
don't know what the tax due taxes yeah
yeah they they want to get ever I think
they want to how long did it take you to
[ __ ] ah depends usually it's pretty fast
do you wash your just wipe I use those
white B those wet wipes wet wipes an but
at the airport you will use web right oh
no no I wish I carried them though I
don't meet you I wish I had them on me
too
you [ __ ] have a mommy I don't I wish
I had a lot of things when I'm taking a
[ __ ] at the airport but like how long
just give me a thing five to ten minutes
relax baby these people twenty thirty
minutes
no that's we come out with your little
briefcase and they do their tie but they
take everything off too I go what did
you unload in there yeah but that's how
you get bullet they're pushing too hard
yes holiday you know after like like
after you do a flush you knew that
someone was gonna come out and some
other person was gonna get a stall so
the slang got shorter but do it was like
slow your breathing yeah when I finally
get in there and I timed it three
minutes see efficient
I just get it out all you need three
minutes actually but not only that is I
know that there's a line so you're like
you know that's a part of it it's not
like yeah it's my time now now they're
gonna way like white people are selfish
well I'm thinking dude is like you
should shoot really quickly because I
know how they're right yeah like you
George I'm tired of people like you all
you look like you take your time at the
[ __ ] you look like a selfish white
guy
[Music]